[موسيقى]
إنه موسم التفاح وهذا يعني أن
أجهزة iPhone الجديدة قد تتساءل عما إذا كان
يجب عليك الترقية، إليك ثلاثة أشياء
يجب أن تضعها في اعتبارك أولاً الشحن
لأول مرة منذ 11 عامًا لقد
غيرت Apple نظام الشحن الخاص بها إذا كنت من مستخدمي
iPhone  أيها المستخدم، هذا هو
الشاحن السريع الذي كنت تستخدمه بالفعل
ولكنك الآن ستتحول إلى USBC وإذا
كنت قد رأيت هذا من قبل فذلك لأن
العديد من الشركات كانت تستخدم هذا
لسنوات، لذا أصبحت تعبئة حقيبتك
أسهل بكثير  يمكنك استخدام
شاحن واحد لأن هذا الشاحن
سيشحن أيضًا الأجهزة اللوحية والكاميرات الرقمية
وأجهزة الكمبيوتر والعديد من الأجهزة المختلفة
ولن تضطر إلى البحث للعثور على الشاحن
المناسب لجهاز iPhone الخاص بك. التالي هو
زر الإجراء الذي قامت Apple بإيقاف تشغيل
كاتم صوت نغمة الرنين الموجود به  بالنسبة
للزر الجديد، فبمجرد الضغط عليه يمكنه
فعل أي شيء تريده أن
يفعله على iPhone 14 وما قبله، وهو
زر يتيح لك تشغيل
وإيقاف مستوى الصوت، وهنا هو
زر فعلي تضغط عليه  يمكنك برمجته
لتشغيل الكاميرا الخاصة بك أو استخدام المصباح اليدوي أو
استخدامه كاختصار لأي تطبيق. لقد قمت ببرمجة برنامجي
لفتح Instagram، فأنت
تعلم أن الطقس سيكون جيدًا أيضًا،
ومن المثير للاهتمام معرفة أن Apple
قررت تشغيل الزر فقط  هناك
شيء واحد مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أن الأمر كله يتعلق
بالتخصيص وتعدد المهام، لذلك
أتساءل عما إذا كنت ستتمكن في التكرارات المستقبلية من
القيام بأكثر من مجرد شيء واحد،
والشيء الآخر الذي يجب أن تضعه في الاعتبار هو إذا
كنت مدمنًا على أشياء معينة مثل
وجود زر في Instagram للاتصال به  من
المؤكد أن الاتصال بنا لن يساعد في حل
المشكلة رقم ثلاثة،
فلنتحدث عن غلاف Apple الجديد المصنوع من التيتانيوم،
تقول Apple إن الغلاف أخف وزنًا
وأكثر متانة ويتم استخدامه من
نفس المادة التي ستجدها في
مركبة فضائية أو مركبة المريخ الجوالة  هذا هو جهاز
iPhone 14 القديم الخاص بي. جهاز iPhone 15 Pro هو
بالتأكيد أخف وزنًا ولكنه ليس
مختلفًا بشكل ملحوظ، هذه
ليست الميزات الجديدة الوحيدة ولكنها
ثلاث من أكبر الميزات، إذا كنت في
السوق لشراء iPhone جديد، فهذا في
الواقع  تشكيلة جيدة حقًا يجب وضعها في
الاعتبار خاصة بسبب
نظام الشحن مرة أخرى، سيختفي منفذ Lightning،
لذا فهي مسألة
وقت فقط قبل أن يستخدم الجميع USBC
[موسيقى]